hold on hold on well Randy Pony Jojo
figures oh wow it's um it's funny you
ask oh thank God thank God I would just
like to preface that that was not a
scripted cuz we were just showing
figures and I remember thinking III say
in the video okay Connors gonna buy Jojo
figures I don't need to buy it
I don't need to buy any Jojo figures
yeah so if you didn't buy any I would
have been like how did we go an entire
[ __ ] trip to a key Harbor without
buying any joke oh boy multiple Jared
your fingers actually because it's all
sides okay good good on Brad so this is
the figure that I've actually never seen
before this is the crazy diamond
Jojo figure and it's the one of the
special colored editions actually I
think is the there's a normal colored
version and I've never seen this figure
before and I've never seen it listed
anywhere or anything but there's two of
them in the store funny enough I hope
somebody like 19 bucks for 19 bucks
that's a really nice figure and if
you've seen Jojo figures you know they
look ABS a charge a lot more for a lot
less effort it's it's tragic that like a
20-buck Vega for the special colored
edition is like way better than I I paid
a hundred twenty also like enjoyed your
figures it's like a double-edged sword
is that like some of them just look like
absolute ass some of them do not look
like the character right and it's kind
of tragic it's like one of the most
influential and popular series in Japan
and they do them dirty but it's a good
thing we can agree on that that is a
beautiful figure my boy should I show my
next figure that I bought I bought a lot
of they stop at ten this is dude I knew
whose ACCA's before we left the store I
and I don't know if we got this on
camera I don't think we did Joe he was
like I was gonna buy this figure and he
pointed to the booth where I got this
figure he was like oh I must've been in
the different booth and I was thinking I
bought the moment like I looked over it
was like a comic I was like I looked
over and it was just gone in my head I'm
just like someone bought it it is how
much that cost it was like 30 bucks 30
bucks
oh cool that is for 30 but it is so it
is not standing up I'm real
now is a cave capabie 4:30
I know goods and like do you see cure
figure no yeah never [ __ ] steal yeah
okay absolutely
that's very cool